buonasera grazie vita allora per parlare
futuro vi racconto velocemente il mio
passato è un pezzo del mio presente
io sono milanese sono figlio di un
industriale
ho studiato quasi fino alla fine e
l'università nel senso che mi mancava un
esame ho fatto la tesi poi ho trovato
una ragazzina della quale mi sono
innamorato sono ho piantato degli studi
non mi sono fidanzato con la ragazzina
ho trovato poi subito dopo un'altra
ragazzina avevo 22 anni che mi ha
raccontato una storia diversa e sono
stato due o tre mesi senza fare niente
poi siccome invece sono una persona che
attiva
ho iniziato a guardarmi in giro e a fare
l'imprenditore
quindi io sono imprenditore da quando ho
23 anni ho fondato varie aziende
prevalentemente nel mondo
dell'abbigliamento alcune anche diciamo
conosciute partecipato alla start up di
un'azienda che forse conoscete si chiama
napapijri ho lavorato
all'inizio con un'altra azienda
americana che si chiama banana republic
e poi nel 96 ho fondato un'azienda che
per prima in italia ha fatto gli outlet
poi però sempre nel 96 è successo che
mia figlia clementina la più grande
si sia ammalata di tumore di un tumore
brutto
si chiama neuroblastoma un tumore che
non era facile da curare e quindi io e
mia moglie abbiamo iniziato ad andare in
giro per il mondo per cercare di curare
la creme e quindi già stati quasi sempre
all'estero un anno a londra tre anni a
new york e nei negli intervalli in giro
per l'italia a genova a monza a milano
dove stavamo noi
poi però la creme a un certo punto dopo
sette anni ha pensato che e migliaia dio
fossimo come dire cresciuti avessimo
capito qualcosa e quindi ci ha lasciato
ma ci ha lasciato con un compito con una
specie di missione che era quella di far
sì che dei bambini come lei i bambini
malati di tumore stessero bene quindi
vivessero quel periodo della malattia
che loro non hanno scelto con però delle
prospettive perché quel periodo
loro ei loro genitori potessero fare
delle cose belle potessero fare delle
cose divertenti e quindi abbiamo fondato
una fondazione che si chiama magica
cleme che porta ai bambini malati di
tumore a divertirsi e noi tutti i
weekend
io sarei dovuto essere questo weekend
oggi per esempio i bambini i miei
bambini con con anche tanti amici perché
poi si uniscono un sacco di amici sono a
visitare questa fabbrica dei trucchi che
è una fabbrica che fa trucchi per tutte
le principali aziende di make up
italiane del mondo weekend scorso siamo
stati a cortina insomma tutti i weekend
e andiamo da qualche parte questa storia
questa questa vita in mezzo ai bambini
in mezzo alle famiglie a mezzo degli
ospedali e dottori ha fatto sì che io
trasformassi pensasse di trasformare la
mia azienda che faceva gli outlet che in
qualche modo in quei sette anni ero
riuscito a mandare avanti in un'azienda
che però non doveva dare un beneficio o
una persona sola non mi piaceva io mi
sento profondamente un imprenditore ma
sono un imprenditore che crede che sia
importante non generare denaro per uno
per pochi ma che possa che l'azienda
possa generare un beneficio al
territorio si possa condividere il
beneficio che dasco possa condividere le
risorse che genera e quindi questa
azienda è stata trasformata in un
azienda che noi chiamiamo impresa
sociale che attraverso dei canali
innovativi di retail
noi facciamo tempo era le altre dentro
le sedi di grandi aziende quindi
vendiamo vestiti di marca facciamo degli
accordi con le marche moncler cornice
eccetera e vendiamo attraverso delle
vendite che durò 12 giorni ai dipendenti
di queste grandi aziende i vestiti
scontati con degli sconti importanti e
ogni volta che si fa una vendita una
percentuale importante da una onlus che
si occupa di progetti sempre relativi ai
bambini
gli adolescenti nel campo della sanità
della cultura dell'educazione in maniera
tale che le aziende e dipendenti
sappiano che comunque con i loro
acquisti
se riesce a creare un beneficio qualcosa
di buono sul territorio di cui puoi
andare anche fieri e orgogliosi
questa azienda poi ha capito che i
dipendenti le persone che lavorano
dentro nelle nelle aziende sono poi le
stesse persone che devono correre in
giro che devono comprare il latte la
frutta e la carne i detersivi e di
conseguenza abbiamo iniziato con un
progetto che si chiama la verdura che
frutta a portare frutta verdura fresca e
dipendenti quindi i dipendenti comprano
la frutta la verdura fresca su un
portale e a costi zero
noi portiamo la frutta la verdura fresca
3 2 3 volte alla settimana in maniera
tale che loro mandano a casa con le loro
sacchettino con dentro due pesche una
mela e tre banane e contemporaneamente
donano sempre a un progetto che insieme
alla loro azienda hanno deciso hanno
condiviso di fianco a questa attività
c'è anche un'altra fondazione che ho
creato che si occupa in questo caso
insieme alla magica che ahimè di
adolescenti malati di cancro in cura
l'istituto dei tumori
questo è un progetto che mi piace di cui
sono orgoglioso i ragazzini quando si
ammalano tendono a non avere più
amicizie si sentono abbandonati sono
sparati fuori dalla società
la prima cosa che uno chiede un altro e
come stai non ci si può più chiedere
quello gli adolescenti diventano pelati
gonfi spesso mutilati e noi abbiamo
generato con loro dei progetti che gli
fanno sentire di nuovo facenti parte di
qualche cosa che che gli dà orgoglio
coraggio e quindi dei percorsi creativi
che fanno quando i professionisti
importanti con delle aziende abbiamo
fatto delle borse con coccinelle
abbiamo fatto i trucchi con mattina
abbiamo fatto una canzone che dopo vi
mostro con faso di elio e le storie tese
stiamo facendo le biciclette a scatto
fisso una collezione di gioielli questi
ragazzi per cinque sei sette mesi
lavorano insieme a dei professionisti si
sentono figli si sentono delle persone
che di nuovo fanno parte del mondo
ecco concludo per potervi far vedere la
canzone io penso che il futuro dipenda
dal passato ma dipenda da noi siamo noi
che ci possiamo costruire il futuro non
pensiamo che sia quello di fianco con lo
stato l'amico l'azienda che può generare
il nostro futuro noi siamo gli artefici
del nostro futuro
dobbiamo crederci e ci dobbiamo mettere
impegno e tanto orgoglio grazie
di lione
riesce a immaginarmi male vi sono
sentire che ci sei anche tu
qui e spinge
andiamo a fare un
lo show
monta
fuori dalla corsa
tira
ecco
lontano
illumina
ciao mondo
che
avere la pelle
sembra niente
noi
per noi
abbiamo gli uguali
via da questo letto sfatto via da quel
dottore marzo bambini per me gusti
andiamo lontano
siamo insieme
vediamo il tramonto di questo mondo
questo
il testone tondo ti prego portano ancora
realtà come ci sono le mie tramonta
dietro la città sparisce
porta di contro un'altra galassia per
dimenticare questa corsia quanta voglia
di casa mia
certe volte mi servirà come camicie di
forza per i pensieri di certe volte
vorrei salire in quanta strada posso
ancora
avrei voluto tante cose fossero andate
male
ma non tutto si può scegliere di
repubblica cose andare avanti
bisogna avere solo una parte in sé la
forza di aspettare quando pensi sia
finita alza la testa ipod a palla e
riprendete la vita la cosa più
solo possa provare
nella consapevolezza di avere un futuro
ed esserne padroni
l'ossigeno
adesso